ke that
at all, John.
No, not my style,
to be sure.
That is a monstrous weapon,
absolutely monstrous.
Reso: Oh, yeah, it is.
That is heavy,
especially up top.
The power and the ability of
this ax is definitely at range.
When this hits, this is gonna do
devastating damage.
To get hit in the head
with this,
I wouldn't be surprised
if you saw somebody
get knocked out.
Now, for
the tournament sport,
you basically have
a flat piece of steel
that's pretty thick.
Historically, an ax blade
actually would have a, uh,
three-dimensional
cross section to it.
So you would actually --
thick along the edge somewhat.
Then it would
thin out again,
and then it would curve up
and thicken again.
And that would reduce
the weight substantially.
And the languets
would also be, um,
a different part
of the blade.
But this piece is adding
some counterbalance to it,
at least.
Now, sometimes it's said
that double-bladed axes
were only used
in ancient Minoa on Crete.
But we have combat images
of blades like this
being used by Franks
and by, uh --
in the 9th century --
by Germans in the 13th century,
and by the French
in the 14th century.
Now, historically,
a blade like this could be used
to hook on pieces of armor
and to rend and tear it.
But, uh, we don't want that
occurring in this sport.
Right.
In the ACL, we do not tear
pieces of armor off
because --
uh, to gain advantage,
'cause we really don't
want to send anybody home
to the hos--
to the hospital.
Yeah.
How 'bout this, um --
the grip down here?
Is that something that's kind
of added,
or was that something
that we actually saw in relation
to the period
that these weapons were used?
All manner
of grips and wraps.
On a modern ax,
you'll see a rubberized grip.
It's the same idea.
With a --
With a gauntlet, you do not want
your hands slipping around.
This is very slippery.
This keeps it planted
in one hand
so you can maneuver
with it.
Especially when you --
in a weapon this heavy,
when you throw it,
it's a possibility
with gauntlets
that it could slip
out of your hand.
You don't want to
lose the weapon.
With the second hand,
you want to be able to hold it
as it follows through.
If you miss a shot,
this ax is going to
come way out of play,
leaving you wide open.